here in Barcelona the battle over
Catalonia's independence has swung at
least for now in favor of the Spanish
government Madrid is in full control now
of the region and there's been little or
no sign of the Democratic resistance
that the separatists had been asking for
my guest here is alfred bosch leader of
the pro-independence republican left on
the city council here will he now admit
that the movement has bitten off way
more than it can chew
[Music]
alfrid Bosch welcome to conflict zone
thank you a new country has been born
those were your words
big words a couple of days ago you spoke
too soon didn't you
no because the Republic is being
proclaimed and now it's a newly born
baby it's small it's fragile and we have
to make it grow
a baby from which the leaders have
already fled to Belgium to escape
possible arrest
that's hardly a glorious start to it is
it well we might see again something we
hadn't seen in Europe for decades which
is politicians looking for a political
asylum within Europe so that's a
development we should follow closely
that's the start to your to your
Republic is it shows the nature of the
Spanish state and have something which
has been eminently democratic which is
being done to respond to a popular
mandate something like that is
absolutely questioned and persecuted by
the Spanish powers so it shows the
nature of your leaders that the first
sign of trouble they were unaware well
obviously we need to pursue an
international agenda and the best place
to do that as Brussels isn't it this
isn't pursuing a international agenda
this is running away isn't it let's
let's let's call it what it is this
wasn't planned was it that they would go
off on some trip to consult foreign
powers this was to get away from the
possibility of being arrested wasn't it
well so reason well obviously the
prosecutor came out yesterday and he
stated all the accusations the offenses
which hang on these people now one of
them is rebellion which could mean up to
30 years in jail
the other one is sedition up to 15 years
etc and you have I suppose they hadn't
considered that well that's a bit
disproportionate isn't it for somebody
who has been a democratically elected
who has organized a vote and afterwards
tries to deliver on that vote now for
ones that politicians deliver we might
as well respect them they really hadn't
considered that possibility they did
banish state would level charges not
that it has done yet but it's
considering okay
the question is why is half of the
Catalan government here in town in
Barcelona why is the other half in
Brussels
obviously the half wishes which is in
Brussels is pursuing the international
agenda the Catalan Republic has to be
recognized they didn't intend to go they
got frightened they got cold feet they
ran away what commander leaves the
battlefield in the middle of the battle
what kind of example is that to
everybody and there they are telling
everybody to resist democratically and
they run as fast as their legs will
carry them well perhaps we should
interview your views and try to find
your view because you you seem to know
very well what those people are thinking
why they're doing these things I'm
trying to give you my vision of this
from within and what I know is that
there's right now two people in jail
they're accused of sedition which was
something about which for instance
Mahatma Gandhi was accused in 1922 and
these guys face penalties of up to 30
years in jail and this is happening we
are having political prisoners in Spain
now why should we have active
politicians in jail when they can be in
Brussels working for the recognition of
the Catalan Republic
that's all Consulting lawyers about how
they stay out there's half of the
Catalan government that's doing exactly
that they are staying here and they're
consulting lawyers to see how can they
can face all these accusations and
penalties you don't think they shouldn't
working out before well maybe but this
is how it is right yes we hang it up as
you go along
well we have half of the Catalan
government abroad working for the
Catalan Republic the other half staying
here facing whatever risks might fall on
them so I think that's quite a logical
and understandable behavior isn't it in
a perhaps things I think happening in an
unexpected way and then you have to take
decisions on the run obviously you mean
that you can't foresee absolutely
everything not everything can be planned
meanwhile the Spanish government is
outmaneuvered you hasn't it's taken
control of the region's administration
with very little opposition of any
grassroot support seems to be being away
doesn't it the Spanish government has
actually
boat down to international pressure and
pressure from other parties because its
plans were and we saw that I mean we
heard raha speaking like week ago and
its plans were clearly not calling for
an election and finally it had to call
for an election and it's acknowledged
that the solution has to pass through
democratic procedures so it has actually
acknowledged Spanish government has
actually acknowledged that by sheer use
of force and by sheer power they won't
solve the question so that's a
development and we we read it in a
positive way it puts them in the driving
seat though doesn't it well me you say
you have a state a state has been born
but there they are they're setting the
date for the elections people are coming
forward and saying yes they'll take part
in the elections pro-independence groups
are saying they'll take part in the
elections to leading catalan unions the
you GT and the ccoo which had supported
the referendum they now back the
elections as well and they oppose any
resistance on the street as a party we
will run for elections obviously we love
elections we love the ballot boxes we
defended them on October the first with
our bodies and citizens who followed
this referendum where they're trying to
help people to vote and they were being
clobbered and they were being beaten up
at that police the elderly ladies whole
families they're defending the vote so
we're not gonna go against the vote
we're gonna go to vote and we'll try and
even if it's the Spanish state that's
managing because it now acquires a
plebiscite Arian kind of sight to it
this vote will be a vote to show who has
the numbers and who has the majority so
we accept it
they threw a glove to us we accept that
that challenge we have to do it and we
are democratic obviously we've pursued
this always in a democratic manner we're
not going to lose that quality and
maintaining all the time the fiction
that you have an independent state that
it's set up and it's enacted well why do
you call it a fiction I mean well sorry
to question you from one of the
political scientists at the Autonomous
University here aureole Bartimaeus who
said yesterday
no if ii quote other scientists who say
other thing he says i don't know if the
separatists can keep up this fiction of
being a real independent republic for
much longer well you see that sounds
very much like the Spanish government's
view because they say exactly that I
wouldn't call it a fiction well in the
sense that when Lithuania was declared
for instance the independence of
Lithuania it looked pretty much like
this it took one year and a half to get
an important recognition more than one
year to get any recognition at all from
other countries they were it was a very
different situation Lithuania had been
illegally annexed and it was accepted by
the Soviet yes completely different
situation more so even more so I mean
obviously in that case the United States
were kind of backing whatever was
happening that and even so it took more
than one year and a half for them to
recognize Lithuania so this kind of
fiction went on for a year and a half
and that wasn't a fiction and meanwhile
well I mean that's an opinion is
respectable but meanwhile the Red Army
was there in fact it stayed there for
ten years
the Red Army occupied the television the
administration offices of Lithuania so
it was pretty much the same you could
have said there nobody recognized
Lithuania the European Union said it
wouldn't recognize it they they backed
Gorbachev in that and those times
so let's come back to Catalonia no no
because these important these
international examples help us they're
all different but they help us to
realize that it's not so strange what's
happening here is not so awkward it's
something very common when a newly born
country is born it is fragile it's
unavoidable and we are fighting against
Spanish power it's a very well
established state it's a kingdom who's
been there for years and it has an army
as a navy it has financial assets
obviously it's hard okay obviously we
have a very little creature and we got a
cater for it and we got an oration
December 21 you're going to take part in
the elections that the Spanish
government will be managing are we going
to see a continuation of some of the
pretty questionable methods used by your
movement before the
the referendum I'm thinking of attempts
to intimidate and pressure those who
didn't agree with you are we going to
see that before the election was never
seen that your son can you give me the
exact I'll give you a concrete your D
ballot member of the Catalan Socialist
Party the PSC which was against the
referendum he described on Facebook the
kind of pressure and intimidation that
he had suffered for opposing the
referendum
they called me a Quisling he said a
turncoat a sellout a coward a wimp
and a traitor they've told me that I'm a
bad Catalan a [ __ ] but I'm a despicable
I'm a disgusting [ __ ] you proud of
that sort of thing not at all the sort
of democracy novela least let me bring
you my cell phone and show you all the
comments I get there hundreds of them
hundreds of them calling me things like
that or even worse I of course it's
crazy people all around especially in
the times of the the global the global
networks but I think Jordi himself has
not suffered physically from anybody he
said has not been attacked but this is
intimidation intimidate okay how would
you compare that for instance to the
1000 people who were injured during the
referendum looked over the first who
were brutalized not by a crazy people
who were brutalized by the State Police
and by the Spanish military police
they attacked just in Barcelona 28
voting stations they have apologized for
the violence who has not Rockley no
Enrique a lot and Rita Miller okay the
Spanish government's representative in
Catalonia he apologized for okay said he
could not help but regret and apologize
on behalf of the officers who intervene
yes but I did the opposite okay so does
the apology mean that that's justified
that's a question you have to put to
them I'm just saying the right thing
obviously ties so but they did it and
apart for that they have two people in
jail for their ideas they're being
accused of sedition again call it
political prisoners how else would you
call it but I'm talking about the
pressure and the intimidation nuria
marine mayor of cattle
only a second her very little a she
complained to President ex-president
puja more about the pressure being put
on her and her colleague she said I told
him what a lot of people are thinking a
lot of my colleagues are having a rough
time putting mares in the cross hairs
won't fix anything it'll just add fuel
to the fire she said yes look who's
being beaten up who's being put in jail
were persecuted who's being who had to
go to exile now you're talking about
people who are still there they're in
office their powers going into exile
they go into exile yes to pursue an
international agenda that's what
governments in exile do exactly that
they run away to do that do they well
they can't do it here because they'll be
put in jail probably like so many other
people have been dealt with so um I
think of course any excess on any side
has to be put forward has to be
condemned and we do it but let's face it
who has the power and who's who's who's
preventing people from voting who's
preventing people from deciding
something and once they decided who's
preventing that decision from taking
place so what did you government to do
they have a mandate as a legally elected
government of expectations nobody no
justice but they have a man we talked
about just don't be very serious about
this I'm very sick we said about
proportion and justice and what I'm
saying is the Spanish government has
never been proportionate has never been
fair now you don't think they would
trigger article one time five and do
what is necessary to defend the
Constitution well unfortunately we
feared they would do it but you know
what article 155 is about the
international press your colleagues
called it a nuclear button that was
imposing direct rule that's ignoring
whatever elections took place in
Catalonia before that's ruling a place
with that going through the ballot box
they offered mr. Poojah more a chance to
address the Senate last week he chose
not to they offered to set up a
commission
constitutional reform you didn't want
that your foreign minister said it was
just a distraction from the legitimate
demands of the Catalan people they said
they talk to you if you just set aside
the gun that you were holding to their
head which was your Declaration of
Independence but you wouldn't do that
going to the to the Senate to be jeered
at to be shouted at that's not a very
how do you know that very nice yes and
I've been there I was I was in Madrid
for four years one whole legislature and
that's where they used to do to me when
I spoke clearly so imagine the Catalan
president going there for that put them
on offered as you know offered talks and
he suspended the Declaration of
Independence on October 10th in order
that it could be holding talks with the
Spanish government but it was only taken
off that with international mediation he
offered it and never heightened accepted
the Spanish government didn't want to
sit at the table so there has been
constant offers to talk about this since
2007 first with a statute of autonomy
it was completely cancelled by the
Constitutional Court who as you know is
a highly politicized Court then the
financial deal the paddle and president
went to Madrid to try and negotiate a
financial deal a financial deal the door
was slammed on his face and then we
offered to talk about a referendum an
agreed referendum it was impossible once
and again I was there in Madrid we
offered it 16 times 16 times mr. ahoy
who was that right there said no we're
not gonna hold a vote on this mister how
do you solve a question a political
question - why does the mayor of
Barcelona
a de couleur who's been highly critical
of your declaration talk about you
advancing at a camicazi pace after what
she calls your mistake in reading of the
results of the Catalan election process
your speed has been the result of
partisan interests a headlong - that has
been consummated with a declaration of
independence that doesn't have the
support of a majority of capital perhaps
because she belongs to a different party
for my perhaps because she's not in
favor of pursuing the freedom of
Catalonia perhaps because she's rule
the city in coalition with the
Socialists who approved and who wrote
with Mariano Rajoy and who agreed to
decree article 155 which imposes direct
rule on bars on Barcelona and Catalonia
as a whole perhaps because she's in that
line and she holds different ideas but
you're asking me anyway we're gonna have
an interview with the mayor Barcelona
you asked for an interview with her but
you're asking so I'm telling you our
view let's pick up that point about the
speed of this drive for independence the
reason was clear wasn't it you've known
the release since June when the catalan
center for opinion studies gave you an
unpleasant wake-up call it said that
only about 41% of Catalans looked like
voting for independence and how many
against it doesn't say forty one percent
forty only forty one percent would vote
for independent that's what they said in
June less than forty one percent against
and in between you have the undecided
but you sort read all the facts but you
saw ease you know but you saw that your
support was waning and you thought if we
don't happen it's not gonna happen so
you rushed things he rushed things we've
been on this for seven years now perhaps
some of the international opinion and
attention has not been here for seven
years constantly but it was seven years
ago that we started this process there
were some consultations here non-binding
nobody took attention of that in Spain
in Madrid after that we asked for the
financial deal nobody listened to that
after that we hold we held a government
consultation non-binding the result was
very clear in favor of independence
so we've been doing this one was in
favor of independence Oh in 2015
separatist parties won the most seats
here but only 48% of the vote yeah and
how many did the unionist parties win I
mean you told me you've told me 39
percent so the difference was really
quite remarkable and we could oppose in
between you have the undecided parties
who are for self-determination but not
for independence let's explain anything
let's look at the polls in the last few
days both show your independence move
with less support than the unis one poll
in El Pais has 55% against the
declaration of independence 41% in
favour another poll for Sigma da still
has the pro unionists ahead of you by
forty three point four to forty two
point five less than one percent you
studied all the right surveys and I can
bring to you some different surveys and
opinion polls if you wish but let's go
to the actual voting when people vote
they decided on independence in favor
percentage voted by ninety percent
against the ten percent percentage you
asking me about some more I'm asking
more than same ones three points more
three percent more than those who
decided for brexit in the UK for xox's
nobody that's exactly the issue nobody
nobody questions brexit even if the
percentage of those who voted separating
from the European is a big difference is
the law can use a mic and referendum it
would be wonderful to be able to express
myself and and say more than one
sentence after yep please
if brexit was voted for by 38% of the
British now here we had 42 percent of
Catalans voting for independence is that
valid why isn't that valid why is it
valid in one case and not in our case
your figures of rope 52 percent voted
for brexit no I'm talking about the
census in both cases as you are I'm
talking about the census I'm talking
about the actual vote but we compared
census reference the census wants to
compare vote to vote then it's actual
reference and it's 52 percent against
90% that's vote to vote if you compare
the same things let's compare the same
90 percent with one side not taking part
okay but they were invited let me remind
of a small detail you had a ballot I
went there I voted like any other
citizen who wanted to vote and you had
the yes option you had a no option and
you can choose in fact there were
hundreds of thousands of people who
voted no to independence so not only was
it possible it was followed by hundreds
of thousands of people now that made up
only 10% so your mandate
which the mayor of Barcelona among
others is contesting you've you've got
why is she contesting the mandate if she
went to vote she voted she said half the
Catalan said she's lucky with it now how
can you go and vote to a binding
referendum because the Catalan
government said it was binding it passed
a law she's saying it was binding and
how it was binding and then you go to
vote and you say that's not binding and
you're not gonna obey your own vote it's
a billion that's a bit bizarre isn't it
syrupy I know that's why I'm contesting
and let's look at the opinions of the
rest of the world since you're leaders
who are consulting with them at the
moment Antonio Tajani president of the
European Parliament couldn't have
spelled it out more clearly no one in
Europe will recognize an independent
Catalonia jean-claude Juncker also pour
cold water on the enterprise we're not
in favor of letting Europe develop so
that tomorrow we'd have 95 Member States
2018 let's let's go back this is clear
enough isn't it do we want to be a
recognised state that's why we're going
for this you're going for recognition
but there isn't any of the mud sir
exactly frogs exactly he got it if we
think we're all if we were already
independent we wouldn't go for it
because we would already be an
independent recognised state and we're
not and that's why we don't feel free
enough in this political environment the
Kingdom is Spain a part of being the
most corrupt country in the world has
tried to prevent us from vote you have
been suppressed and if you think this is
the most corrupt most of the countries
in the world but that's not the issue
the the king of Spain I strike to
prevent a vote from taking place
it has given orders the police to beat
up people you saw the images all over
the world now what do you think of that
is that a place where you would like to
stay in would you really like to stay in
a place where they try to put in jail
leaders elected leaders where they try
to beat up your grandmas and grandpas at
a place where you would actually take
the law your big problem no big
stumbling block is the constitution of
1978 which Catalonia accepted over
and which makes reference to the
indissoluble unity of the Spanish nation
you're on risky legal ground here you
know but you know it yeah that's exactly
true
that's exactly why we want to change it
because we thought that wasn't
changeable you were offered a commission
to change the Constitution and you just
laugh at that no what's the Commission
if you compare it with the vote of the
people
first the do you believe in residence do
you believe in citizen rights do you
believe in people's empowerment we do
and that's why we do you think that's
more important there's more after the
law no but we think that after seven
years of denials of constant and
repeated denials by the spanish
government we have a right to propose to
our people to take a vote and to decide
on that one catalan professor in the
21st century one catalan professor of
constitutional law at the autonomous
university teresa freshest thinks you're
dead wrong
she says independence is legally just
not possible you can't simply hold a
referendum and complete and proclaim
independence a state has to be
recognized by the UN without recognition
we would be just like Western Sahara or
the Palestinians or Northern Cyprus is
that what you I know that is a fresher
she was a colleague of mine because she
teaches this stuff yes I was a professor
with her very close to her and I also
taught about international history and
from there we had many discussions now
my experience as a professor as a doctor
in international history is that the
people ultimately decide what they want
to what the one who have which kind of
state they want to live in and it's up
to the people to decide that and the
laws can be changed if you can change
the laws we would still have slavery and
if we use women's votes no women's
rights they were really an of type in
South Africa I studied the case of South
Africa for a long time I just one final
question running
against the Constitution against the
laws which were completely unfair
obviously if you lose the elections
December 21st will you forget about this
let's talk after the elections about
this we're gonna win those elections we
have won them all the last elections
we've won so why shouldn't we also win
these we're ready to go to the polls
we love the polls we protect them with
our bodies so let's go there let's vote
and let's turn this into a pleasure site
we accept the challenge
Alfred Bosch good to have you on Complex
[Music]
you